So here's the application that you're
going to build over the next few
minutes.
It's a simple app that gives you
your latitude and your longitude,
helping you to accurately
position yourself on the globe.
Now as you can imagine, there's lots of
great uses for this kind of information.
One of the first mobile apps I
personally ever built was for
dog walkers.
They would run the app when they
walked the dog for someone else so
that the dog's owner could
see the path of the walk.
It worked by taking a very
accurate latitude and
longitude reading every few seconds.
In this case, of course,
we're just taking it once.
But let's see how you would do that.
Let's see how you would get
that type of information.
In the previous lesson, we were getting
continuous updates on the location, but
in this one we're going to
do it a little differently.
We're going to get the latitude and
longitude only once upon connection.
Now I think it's important
to learn by doing, so
we're going to learn how to build
this application by stepping through
what needs to be done little by little.
So if you haven't already done so, open
Android Studio and create a new project.
Give it a name, in this case
I'm calling it Location2_1, and
you're going to pick it to
have a single blank activity.
So you can see here in this option
I'm going to say blank activity,
I'm going to give it
a single blank activity, and
I'm going to keep all the defaults.
And when Android Studio's finished doing
its thing, you'll have your project
created for you, and the activity,
generally by default, is opened.
But if it isn't,
just find the layout folder and
look for
activity_main within that folder.
Then you can see that this is
the basic hello world layout that's
created for you.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to just take a look at the tags
for this, and
we can see in here there's a TextView
simply containing the words hello world.
In the next couple of steps we're
going to change this to update it for
the UI that we showed in
the demonstration just a moment ago.